>>eanine: CEOsT WOKECORPORATNS N
NOTI.SENATOR TOM TTON TEARING IO
KROGER BOSFOR ASKING G.O.
FOR LP TO STOP DEMRATSLA
REGUTIONS AFTER THCHAI
RENTLYILENCED CONSERTIVE
EMPLEES.
>> I HE CAUTIONETHEMORYEARS TH E
NSERVATIVES ANSENATE TO
ITE TERSCROSTHE UNTRY.
AND TH DISIMINATE AGAINS
THEMN THCOUNTRY THEY
PROBABLY SULDN, AND KED
REPUICAN SENATORS  CAR THE
WATER R THEM WOUR DEMOCRAT
FRIENDS WA TO GULATE THEM BLOCK.
I LL SAY THIS, I SRY TS
ISAPPENING TO YO
ST OF LUCK
>> Jeane: T DISNEY DOE'T
EM TBE TAKING THTHREAT
SERISLY.
DEITE THE PROME TO QUIET
THIN DOWON THE CULTUREARS,
SNEY TOP DOG BOBICHESEE
PEOP IN POR HAVE "EXTRA
RESPONSIBITY TO PUSH THI
NTRO"
NA, FIRST WANT TO ADESS
THE NCEPOF TOM COTTON
GETTING OUTHERE AND SAYI,
"YOU KNOWHAT, WE WILL STT
DRAWING LIS  THE SAND."
U EXPECT US TOELP YOU WHEN
YOU ARE COTANTLY COMING THIS CAE
WERE T EMPLOYEES OF OAKE
THAT WERE NSERTIVES THAT G
FIRED CAUSE OF THEIRELIE.
AND EN TY GO TO TOM COON
Dana: IHINK THAT E
REPUICAN PARTY ANDORPORATE
AMICA HAVE BEEN EWINFOR
SOMEIME.
AND I THINK FEVER PITCH WHEN
GEORA PASSED THE N VOTG
WS AND ALL OF A DDEN YOU HAD
COMPANIELIKEELTACOCA-COLA
D MAR LEAGUE BASEBALL, DIDMENTIY
SAIDHAT WAS A RACIST VOTE
SUPPSSOR IN ORGIA.
ANTHEN MOVED OUTTHEY HADT EVENE.
BUT THEY WILCOME TO THE
REPUICANS AND SA OH, MY
GOSH, YOU VE TO HELPS.
YOU DON'T LIEVE WH THE
AZY BERALS WANT TOO.
EY WANT TO LAYFFEOPLE.
ANWE WILL NOT BEOMPETITIVEIN THD
WEEED TO REPUBLINS THELP
US ITOM COTTON, GUYS WHO HAVE
TO PAY AENTI HERE.
YOU CHSE TRUN A BUNESS OR
BEOLITAL, BUT YOU WI NOT
BE ABLE TOBOTH AND COMTO
ME.
>>eanine: YOU KN, HAROLD,WHEN DT
GOT INTO LEGD DON'T SAY GAY
FLAW IN ORIDAND DeSANTIS
TOOKT RIOUS AND 'S GONE.
BUT BOEICH HAS HIS OWN W
GOG ON
WHDON'T THE HEADS OF
CORPORATIONSTAY  THE LANE
INTOUT THEY DO AND LET THE
POLITIANS AL WITH THE OTR
STUFF?
Harold: BECAU I TNK WE
LIVEN A CIETY WHERE
EVERYBODY FES THAT THEY ARPART D
ERYONE SEES WH IS PPENING.
I INK THE SNEY CEO HAS A
FRDOM RATE OF EECH TO
SHAREHOLDERSND OERS IN THE
COMPY.
E BOD DOESN'T WANT THAT,
TH CAN EXCUSTHE  MUCH LIKE
THEYID THE PREDECESS.
BUT I THOUGHT U WAS GOG TO
GN
I S DIPPOINTED WITH
TOM COON A ON PAPER HE IS
ALIFIED, A VETERAN,  I
HAARD UCATED, HARVARD
TRAINED.NOT NSERVATIVEUT THEROJT
DON'T MAKE SENSEME.
YOCANNOT SAY TO CONSTUENT
YOU OR CONSTITUENCY, 'M
MAD AT YOU, LI A 7EAR-D."
I AM STILL MAD AT YOU BUT OU
N'T AGREE WITHHEM, THAT IS
ONE THING.
I THK THAT IS THE WRG THG
TOUT TAXES.
I THINTHATTHE ONG ING
WI LESS RELATIS IN THE
DUSTRY.
I THINK IT IS ONG  CPETE
AGAIT CHINA.
BUT  ALLOU ARE SAYING  YOU
ARA MEDICAMEEMINDED ME
WHEN GERNODeSANTIS GOT
HIMSELF -- HE WOULD GO ON
"THEIEW" BECAUSE HTHOUGHT
E HOST WERE ME.
YOUAN'T HANDLE THVIEW,
U CAHANDLE TRAIN AEARE
FOR TOM COTTON,  SAIIT.I'M NOT .
I'M NOT GOING TOUBJE MYSELF.IF I
WOULNEVER SAY TO RUBLICAN
NSTITUENTS IF U CA THE
OFFICE ANDANT LP WITYOUR
PASSRT, I WILL NOTOING TO DO
IT BECAUSE I'MAD AT U.
THEY CD AND SA WE WAOUTO VOTE RE
PEOPLEO HA GUNS D SAY, YOU
KN WHAI DON'T WANT TDO I
ANHERE IS WHY PURITYAS WRO
AND WHATE SAID.
AND I THINK YOU WILLGREE.
>> Dana: T QUESTN IS AND
WHAT HAROLD  TALNG ABOUT,
JEE, W NOT TAKE VANTE OF
THE PORTUNITY.
T SO DOWN E ROAD THAT YOU
OW, DEMOCRATS N'T DO
YTHING TO HELPEPUBCANS AND
E REPUBLICANS E SAYING, ITIS OU.
Jesse: ALL OF THESE
POLICIANARE TOTALLY BOHT
OFBYHESE CPANIES ANYWAY.
TH HAVBEEN TALKING SH A
BIG ME ABOUT WHAT EY WE
GOING TO DO  THEIG TECH.
WEILL EAK UP BIG TECH.
HOW LONG HE THEY BEEN YING
THATOME A DECADE
ISE XES ON T HEDGE FUND,
HOW MA YEA?
D TH EVER DO IT?
EY NEVER DO IT
U GO AER B PHARMA AND BI
FA IT TAKES A PINE CLUB YS A
FINEBREAKS THEAW.
WHATILL EY DO BREAK UP THE
MERGS?
MAYBE E ORWO MERGERS BUT
THEY STILLET PD.
LOBBST DON'T GETAID.THEY JUST R.
IT IS AT HPENS, YOU GET
SENATOR WHO GETS M
OH, REALLY Y HAVE A OBLE
Y DON'T YOUR STER-IN-LAWJOINHE ?
D TH IT DOESN'T MATTER,
DON'T DISCLO IT.
TA TO E BOOK
AND, AND THETOCKPTIONS
TRANSFERLE.
OH, U STL HAVE A PROEMBECAUSE WU
PRIMARY PLT.
OH, YOKNOW WHAT, YOU NA
CATION.
I AN AACT-FINDING MIION.
WEILL ND IT D WEAVE ONE
MEETING ABOUT VIROENTAL
IMCT STUDY AND T REST OF TTIME ,
HALD, AND YOU WE THEYOU KNOWETT.
>>arol IISSED OUON
THIS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: ROLDTHEY AREEVERYWRE .
THEYAVE  ARMOF LOBBYISTS LOBBYI.
>> JnineTHANK YOU VERY
MUCH,.
>> Gre I WOULD DAGREE
MILDLY WITH ROLD
COM OFFLMOSA LILE
SNOTTY OR ALTRST B HE'SLOOKING E
NEXT OPPORNITY.
I INK HE'S TRYINTO SAY LOO
TRWORKG WI US D WEILL
WORK WITH YOU T RIGHT W ITKIND .
BUT I INK THE TIGERSF THE
WOD WHARE THE REAL SFISH
JERKS.
THEYON'TNDERSTAND WHATS
HAPPENG TO THEIR EMPYEES
ITUCKSOR THE EMPLOYE THATTHESCOP
EXECUTIVESR VIRTUAL SIGNALING
OR CSING GSP POLICS.
THEY A TRYG TO COVER THEBUTTS OS
OKINAT THEM.
THEY WANTO AEARCOMPASSIATE  THEO
ARE RY WE SO TY DON'T
WRE ABOUT MYONUS, RIGHT?
BECAUSE REMBER THAT ISLL
THEYRITE ABOUTORPOTIONS,SO-AND-N
BONUS.
ITS SOUCH TTERHEY SAY,
THE CEO PUISHEA BO O YOU
KNOWINTEECTIONALITY.
BUT U THK -- WHAT HAPPENIS
E BRD BECOMES TOC, WHICH
WHAT WILL HAPN WITH DISNEY.NOWH
ERIC DOLL.
THEYRIEDO FTEN-
EVERODY KNOWTHATAMERICAN
DOLL" IS PULAR BUTVERPRICED.
IT IS RIP-F AND WHY I NO
LONGER BUY MY RNITE THERE
BECAUSE YOKNOW, JUST A TINLITTL.
THEY TRIED TO SOFTEN TIR
APPEAL BY DOING THISITTLBOOK
TELLING KIDSOW TTRANSITION,
YOU KNOW, ANI DON'T EVEN KW
THEARE SPONDING,"ARICAGIRL RES.
>>ana: LET'S GO ER TRE.>> JeaniR
ERE.
Dana: LAST NIT INST